طريق ترامب المرشح الابرز للحزب الجمهوري
لن يكون مفروشا كما يبدو فهو يواجه منافسه
قويه مع مرشحين جمهوريين اخرين في السباق
الرئاسي لعام 2024 فمن هم منافسوه ومن هو
الاوفر حظا بينهم مايك بنز نائب ترامب
عندما كان رئيسا لامريكا اذ يعتبر بنز اول
نائب رئيس يتحدى مباشره الرئيس الذي وضعه
بالمنصب في الاصل منذ نحو 83 عاما وهناك
مرشحه جمهوريه ايضا تنافس ترامب وهي
نيكيهالي التي كانت حاكمه سابقه لولايه
كارولينا الجنوبيه وسفيره ترامبا سابقه
لدى الامم المتحده عندما كان رئيسا
لامريكا بين عامي 2017
و21 الحاكم السابق لولايه نيوجيرسي كريستي
اعلن ايضا دخوله السباق الى البيت الابيض
مقدما نفسه على انه الجمهوري الوحيد
القادر على مواجهه ترامب حديثه السابق
الذي اصبح من اشد خصومه الان فيما رد
ترامب على ترشح كريستي بالقول انه حاكم
فاشل قائمه منافسين ترامب تضم ايضا حاكمه
ولايه فلوريدا
المرشح الثاني الاوفر حظا بعد ترامب وفقا
لاستطلاعات رايه وعندما اعلن ديسانس ترشحه
بشكل رسمي قال عنه ترامب انه سيحتاج الى
عمليه زرع شخصيه شاركونا ارائكم برايكم من
سيكون الفائز بهذا السباق